salut avant de vous donner l'énigme du
jour je vous donne la réponse de
l'énigme d'hier si vous n'avez pas vu
l'énigme d'hier regardez là puisque là
dans quelques secondes je vais vous
donner la réponse est donc vous pourrez
pu avoir le plaisir de la résoudre
puisque vous connaissez déjà la réponse
est la réponse à la question c'est
simplement que claude est une femme
donc forcément ce n'est pas le frère de
franck mais simplement sa soeur et
maintenant l'énigme énigmes numéro
quatre énigmes un petit peu plus
difficile on va dire 4 sur 5 en
difficulté imaginez que vous arrivez
devant un grand trésor
sauf qu'au lieu d'être une pomme ce sera
un diamant mais devant ce trésor est un
génie qui barre la route
il est comme ça et pour passer il faut
réussir à poser une question au génie
mais une question à laquelle il sera
incapable de répondre
mais le problème c'est que le ce génie
là c'est tout c'est tout il a tout la
culture et toutes les connaissances
possible il sait tout et il a la qualité
de son défaut c'est qu'il ne peut pas
mentir donc le génie doit toujours dire
la vérité
il sait tout et pourtant vous devez lui
poser une question à laquelle il sera
incapable de répondre
elle est plus compliquée cette énigme
c'est clair mais dans ces cas-là trouver
la réponse est encore plus intéressant
si vous la trouvez mettez dans les
commentaires que vous avez trouvé mais
ne dévoile et surtout pas la réponse
mais est également un pouce en l'air des
vous avez la réponse sur un moins deux
pouces en l'air je pense sur celle ci
puisqu'elle est plus compliqué mais
encore une fois ça nous permettra de
voir quel est le nombre de personnes qui
a trouvé la bonne réponse par rapport au
nombre de vues profiter encore et
toujours du soleil j'espère qu'il fait
beau là où vous êtes passé un bel été
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner à la
chaîne et de partager ses vidéos puisque
le mental blog c'est une vidéo par jour
pendant un an
là on est sur la série d'été un peu plus
tranquille rendez vous demain à 17h ciao